en direct françois poulet mathis
journalistes et spécialistes des
institutions européennes bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors on attend cette conférence
de presse commune des manuels macro est
et dans gala merkel l'objectif c'est de
relancer l'économie en europe de
redonner du souffle en tout cas au 27
à votre avis que faut-il attendre de
cette conférence de presse de cette
réunion qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui pour
bien comprendre le contexte dans lequel
initiative qui va être proposée par
emmanuel macron et angela merkel comment
cette initiative arrive faut bien avouer
que l'europe a été quasiment absente
dans le démarrage de cette crise elle
n'a pas su trouver les mots elle a pas
su trouver les méthodes les frontières
se sont refermées et les pays finalement
on adopter chacun des stratégies
différentes et donc face à cenon europe
cette situation d'absence de l'europe
emmanuel macron comme angela merkel ont
tous deux convenu et en particulier le
muy mai dernier lorsqu'il se sont
communiquées par téléphone qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose sinon l'europe
pouvait effectivement être en situation
de danger mortel comme le dit lui-même
et jacques delors et donc quel type
d'initiative
bien sûr l'europe étant absente au
démarrage de la crise est ce que
l'europe sera présente au moment il
faudra sortir de cette crise et c'est
bien là la question de quelle manière
l'europe peut-elle agir anguila merkel
vient de déclarer il ya quelques
instants que finalement elle a elle même
reconnu qu' aucune solution ne peut
venir par chacun des pays
pris séparément il faut donc une
solidarité elle paraît aujourd'hui
obligatoire
cela dit les différences sont
considérables entre l'europe du nord et
l'europe du sud l'europe du nord ne veut
absolument pas entendre parler du de
manière de mutualisation de la dette
finalement de faire en sorte que les
pays du nord payent pour les dettes des
pays du sud
ce qui n'est pas acceptable pour eux
mais il va bien falloir relancer
l'économie relancer la machine
jusqu'à maintenant on a à faire face à
une initiative qui est importante qui
est celle de la commission européenne
qui propose qui a proposé et qui
proposera face aux chefs d'état et de
gouvernement le 28 mai prochain
une initiative qui permettra d'envisager
un emprunt de 1000 milliards d'euros
pour relancer l'économie européenne
c'est considérable alors il faut voir si
la france et l'allemagne dans ce cadre
là peuvent proposer une initiative de
manière plus ciblée et en particulier
par exemple donné l'initiative de
relance européenne mais qu'ils ne soient
pas forcément une relance pour revenir à
l'europe d'avant faire une rampe
exactement comme elle était avant
c'est peut-être l'occasion inespérée au
niveau européen d'engager des réformes
des investissements qui permettent une
économie un peu plus verte un peu plus
ouverture environnement bref c'est de
cette initiative là qu'il s'agit alors
vous allez détailler un peu lol les
contours de cette initiative en parlant
de la transition écologique de la
relance économique et la santé sur ce
point là précisément on a beaucoup
entendu à emmanuel macron au plus fort
de l'épidémie dans l'hexagone parler
d'un plan de santé européens qui étaient
nécessaires
alors bien sûr la santé sur la santé
l'europe pas été crédible dans la mesure
où effectivement chaque pays a suivi sa
propre trace sa propre initiative
et puis on l'a vu entre les divergences
de préparation par exemple entre
l'allemagne et la france
le fait que finalement cette crise a été
vécue de manière très différente entre
l'allemagne et la france
tout ça n'a pas facilité une unité de
vues sur la politique en matière de
santé
alors quoi faire de quelles initiatives
peut-on parler il ya déjà des choses
toutes simples pour éviter la cacophonie
qui a existé au moment du démarrage de
cette crise notamment en ce qui concerne
l'approvisionnement l'approvisionnement
en masque ou en matériel de réanimation
et bien là il faudra peut-être veiller à
ce que l'europe soit un peu plus prête à
faire ensemble
peut-être par apprendre relance sûrement
en matière hospitalière pour coordonner
les efforts industriels notamment en ce
qui concerne le matériel de santé le
matériel de réanimation
aussi peut-être pour avoir une attitude
un peu plus commune et pour que les
fermetures de frontières ne se
traduisent pas finalement en fermeture
de dialogue
il est très important on l'a vu que les
médecins que les spécialistes de la
santé se parlent et said échanger leurs
expériences pour un c'est essayer
d'avancer et bien plus que jamais je
pense que c'est l'occasion aussi sur ce
terrain là d'éviter les erreurs qui ont
été commises au début de démarrage de la
crise ce que je parlais tout début de ce
journal un juste avant de commencer de
la stratégie de déconfinement qui a
donné vraiment véritablement
l'impression au niveau européen que
chacun finalement avancé ses pions en
ordre dispersé oui mais là il faut pas
se tromper il faut pas considérer que
sur le problème du déconfinement les
choses doivent être vécues de manière
nationale d'ailleurs on voit bien en
france le déconfinement ne se fait pas
de la manière
entre la france de l'ess et la france de
l'ouest et du sud-ouest et en italie
c'est pareil les situations sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes en entre l'italie
du nord il était allé luxueux alors
françois voulait mettre si je vais vous
anglais font parce qu'on voit emmanuel
mettront qui s'apprête donc à répondre
aux questions des journalistes après
donc son entretien en visioconférence
avec angela merkel on va l'écouter
alors vous avez suivi avec nous ces deux
allocutions à retenir donc ce la
création d'un fonds à le recovery fund
un fonds de solidarité de 500 milliards
d'euros
comment va se structurer ce fond on a
entendu quelques pistes alors on n'a pas
tous les détails tout à fait mais il ya
quelque chose de très important dans ce
qui vient d'être annoncé par angela
merkel emmanuel macron sexuelle une
certaine forme d'acceptation d'une
solidarité financière européenne et
jusqu'à battant cette solidarité
financière faisait défaut et en
particulier sur le plan budgétaire
orlov ce à quoi on assiste c'est
finalement une acceptation par les deux
parties l'allemagne et la france mais
espère ton peut-être par l'ensemble de
l'offre due
une utilisation non pas des dettes
existantes mais d'une mutualisation de
l'effort budgétaire
ça veut dire que ces 500 milliards il va
falloir qu'ils s'investissent qu'ils
s'investissent dans des projets
rentables dans des projets utiles et qui
permettent effectivement à l'europe de
se remettre sur pied
ça c'est très important parce que
jusqu'à maintenant en matière budgétaire
on était vraiment dans un fossé qui
séparait très nettement les pays du nord
et les pays du sud or là on voit
s'esquisser le démarrage le début d'une
solidarité financière qui jusqu'à
maintenant n'existe pas ça c'est très
important sur le plan de la santé on en
a parlé tout à l'heure avant cette
conférence de presse il s'agit bien d'un
plan de santé pour éviter effectivement
tout ce qui a pu se passer en matière de
basques de matériel sanitaire mais aussi
pour mutualiser par exemple les achats
faire en sorte que notre indépendance
sur le plan sanitaire soit plus ou plus
importante vis-à-vis des autres pays
éviter par exemple que l'ensemble des
médicaments soient fabriqués à
l'extérieur de leur faire en sorte
effectivement qui solidarité européenne
plus grande sur le plan industriel
et puis autre aspect très important dont
j'ai évoqué un petit peu la réalité
juste avant cette conférence de presse
c'est le souci de faire en sorte que ce
qu'on appelle ce que la dir est un
président de la commission européenne
appelée le green deal c'est à dire
l'enjeu vers lorgé de transformation
écologique soit inclus dans cet
investissement important que l'europe
doit faire donc je crois que c'est la
première fois que depuis plusieurs mois
que l'allemagne et la france sans
entente véritablement sur une stratégie
et ça je crois que ça faisait défaut on
le regrettait on a vu l'absence de
l'europe avant la crise est là c'est
peut-être les skis ce les esquisses
d'une reprise en main d'une europe qui
jusqu'à maintenant a été très défaillant
alors c'est vrai on a entendu donc cette
solidarité européenne cette initiative
germano française on a entendu aussi la
relance d'une souveraineté économique
et puis ce mot aussi la dette parce que
finalement ce que l'on comprend avec ce
fond c'est que
on va s'endetter finalement oui mais de
manière un petit peu différence il n'est
pas question que ce fonds servent à
combler des trous
sinon ça n'a pas de sens donc la
vocation de ce fonds de 500 milliards
c'est de l'investissement c'est de
relancer la machine
si par là ça ça se traduit par de la
dette
il s'agit de bonnes dettes vous savez
très bien qu'il ya la bonne dette et il
ya la mauvaise d'être la mauvaise dette
c'est celle qui est la dette du puits
sans fonds c'est les dépenses publiques
qui n'ont pas d'effet que sur l'économie
la bonne dette c'est celle qui se
traduit par des investissements en
matière de transformation économique en
matière de modernisation économique de
rendre l'économie plus verte ça c'est de
la bonne dette
il s'agit donc de dette qui pourrait se
contracter sur cette base
or une dette qui est bonne qui est saine
c'est pas une mauvaise dette et donc
c'est ça que finalement allemagne comme
france reconnaisse des deux côtés avec
pour investissement y aura des retours
sur investissement c'est ce qu'il faut
comprendre des investissements dans la
protection sanitaire la transition
écologique de secteurs d'avenir
bien sûr c'est surtout le sait les
quatre piliers de cette nouvelle
stratégie européenne sont très
importants que ce soit le pilier de la
santé et là on sent très bien parce que
tous les pays ont vécu quand même une
crise inédite est d'une gravité
exceptionnelle tous les pays s'accordent
ou vont s'accorder on peut le penser
sur la priorité d'une politique un peu
plus concertée et même beaucoup plus
concertée en matière de santé mais le
deuxième aspect qui est sur le plan
budgétaire j'en parlais à l'instant le
fait d'imaginer quand même que sur le
plan budgétaire on puisse avoir une
meilleure solidarité que celle qui a
existé avant ça c'est important
troisième chose en matière écologique et
quatrième pilier en matière de
souveraineté la souveraineté c'est pas
considéré que les frontières c'est des
frontières c'est sacré c'est sacré ce
qui est sacré ce qui est important c'est
que l'europe retrouve une autonomie soit
un peu plus maître de son activité de
son économie ce qui n'était plus le cas
en particulier en matière de santé on le
voit avec la pénurie des médicaments ou
de matériel médical donc c'est
c'est bien de ça dont il s'agit faire
que l'europe retrouve à la fois une
autonomie une souveraineté et peut-être
j'ajouterai comme pierre angulaire une
certaine forme d'énergie qui lui à
chaque membre ok merci beaucoup pour
cette note n'enthousiasme françois
poulet mathis vous rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes